Christian bells gonna play our villain
which is gonna be fantastic yeah it's
gonna be good
Tessa Thompson is spilling some brand
new secrets about for love and thunder
and only et has the exclusive details we
cannot wait to finally watch the
Valkyrie come back into our lives for
love and thunder what can you give us
you have you read the scruff chat head
yeah I've read the script I can't tell
you much but lots of exciting text
messages exchanged between Natalie and I
we're gonna have fun we're gonna have
fun you know tyka is writing directing
some familiar faces some new people into
the mix Christian Belle's gonna play our
villain which is gonna be fantastic
yeah it's gonna be good one last
question is right now she's the king of
Asgard will she maintain that title oh
yeah she's know of course she will she's
Queen she's a king
no she's king if she can't find her
acquaintance she'll just be king and
queen at the same time for Tessa takes
back her crown on Asgard you can catch
her mysterious return as Charlotte Hale
on season 3 of Westworld
[Music]
against an entire world it'll be in that
phone I'm so excited I haven't seen the
show yet at all so I'm I'm elated
let's talk about season three if season
one was about the maze and season two
was about the door what do you think
season three is about I think it's about
destiny I think it's about whether or
not we control our own yeah I think it's
about season two was amazing but
sometimes hard to follow
do you feel like season three is gonna
be a little bit easier to understand I
mean it's certainly more linear so maybe
that will be easier for people to
understand I mean I think this show
always once s really complicated
questions this this experience this
season I think it's very visceral and
once you're inside the engine you're
just you're going so I don't think you
have a you know you can't decide whether
you there's no choice but to follow I
think that's the way I'll say
[Music]
real gods are coming
never angry
[Music]